my name is lauren price i'm a networking
specialist customer engineer at google
cloud and today i'm going to talk to you
about the networking concepts for cloud
data fusion that are helpful to know for
implementation security and connectivity
[Music]
cloud data fusion is google cloud's
native managed service for enterprise
data integration and ingestion
it provides a visual point and click
interface enabling a code-free
deployment of etl and elt data pipelines
cloud data fusion has a number of
components that exist behind the scenes
that power the service and it creates a
tenant project and vpc to hold those
resources
the data fusion components that are
surfaced to the user are the data fusion
instance and the data proc clusters
each cloud data fusion instance contains
a unique independent cloud data fusion
deployment that contains a set of
services that handle pipeline lifecycle
management orchestration coordination
and metadata management
cloud data fusion creates ephemeral
execution environments to run pipelines
when you manually run your pipelines or
when pipelines run through a time
schedule or a pipeline state trigger
cloud data fusion uses dataproc as an
execution environment in which you can
choose to run pipelines as spark or
spark streaming programs cloud data
fusion provisions an ephemeral dataproc
cluster in the user project at the
beginning of a pipeline run
executes the pipeline using mapreduce or
spark in the cluster and then deletes
the cluster after the pipeline execution
is complete
alternatively if you manage your
dataproc clusters in controlled
environments you can also configure
cloud data fusion not to provision
ephemeral clusters and run pipelines
against existing proc clusters instead
the cloud data fusion instance can be
thought of as the design environment and
the dataproc cluster as the execution
environment
there are two types of cloud data fusion
instances based on an access model a
public instance which is the default
deployment and a private instance
let's dig into the access patterns from
different scenarios
we can start with the public ip
deployment pattern
in a public instance network
communication happens over the open
internet regardless of the source
location which is not recommended for
critical environments
the cloud data fusion instance for the
design environment will have a public ip
however the data proc cluster used for
the execution environment can be
deployed with either public ip or
private ips
let's move on to the private ip
deployment pattern
cloud data fusion private ip has
different setup steps depending on
whether you are using a standard vpc or
a shared vpc network
if you're using a standard vpc you can
create the instance using either the
cloud console or a curl command however
if you are using a shared vpc you must
use a curl command check out the
documentation that's linked in the
description for more information when
private ip instances are created a
separate tenant project is created for
each user project in which cloud data
fusion instances are provisioned
additionally cloud data fusion private
ip requires a peering connection to
communicate privately with sources
located in the user vpc and is required
for the design environment capabilities
this parent connection must be created
manually
if you need to access a public source
using a private ip cloud data fusion
instance when designing pipelines you
must use version 6.4 or above
in the design environment cloud data
fusion traffic will traverse a vpc pier
from the tenant vpc to the user vpc
traffic will then be directed to an
internal load balancer fronting a
managed instance group of gateway vms
traffic will egress through the gateway
vms through a cloud nat configured for
the subnet and to the public source on
the internet
the dataproc cluster used for the
execution environment should be
configured to egress through the
cloudnet as well to reach the public
source
for sources that are hosted within the
uservpc cloud data fusion will connect
over a vpc pier
firewalls must be configured in the
source vpc to allow the source to
communicate with the cloud data fusion
instance as well as the dataproc
execution environment
if you are in a peered hub and spoke
architecture model and you are trying to
make a connection from a vpc that is not
directly peered to the cloud data fusion
tenant vpc you must use a proxy due to
the non-transitive routing nature of
google's vpcs
this will only be needed for the design
environment
be aware you can also replace a peering
hub and spoke architecture with a vpn
hub and spoke model so that the cloud
data fusion 10 and vpc route can be
advertised over the
vpn non-transitive peering also comes
into play when trying to connect to a
google cloud source that is deployed
using another tenant project for example
cloud sql
cloud data fusion and cloud sql are both
hosted in tenant projects but these
projects are different in order for
cloud data fusion to connect to a cloud
sql source a proxy vm must be deployed
in the user vpc to proxy traffic to the
cloud sql instance when using the design
environment since the data proc clusters
used in the execution environment are
hosted in the user vpc they will be able
to connect to cloud sql without the use
of the proxy
when accessing sources in an on-prem
environment with cloud data fusion
private ip a hybrid connection must
exist between the user vpc and the on
prime environment
either an havpn or interconnect can be
used both the ipsider range for the
tenant vpc where the cloud data fusion
instance is hosted as well as the ip
citer range of the dataproc cluster in
the uservpc must be advertised over the
hybrid connection and on-prem firewalls
must be configured to accept ingress
from these ranges
if the vlan or vpn lands in another
peered vpc then you'll need to use a
proxy to connect the source to the cloud
data fusion instance
when accessing data sources both public
and private instances make outgoing
calls to google cloud apis using private
google access let's briefly cover some
security topics
for cloud data fusion versions below 6.5
you can only manage access at an
instance level if you have access to an
instance you have access to all
pipelines and metadata in that instance
for version 6.5 and above you also have
the ability to use role-based access
control to establish name-space level
isolation within a single cloud data
fusion instance this feature is
currently in preview
pipeline access to data is provided by
granting access to the service account
which can be a custom service account
that you specify
you must make sure that the service
account has proper iam permissions in
place to access any google cloud-hosted
data sources
for a pipeline execution you control
ingress and egress by setting the
appropriate firewall rules on the user
vpc on which the pipeline is being
executed
before we wrap up let's summarize the
three most important takeaways from
today
cloud data fusion exists as a design
environment that runs within a tenant
project in vpc and an execution
environment that runs as a dataproc
cluster within the uservpc
cloud data fusion can be launched with a
public ip or private ip and vpc peering
must manually be configured between the
tenant bpc and user vpc for private ip
firewall rules must be configured to
allow connections to and from both the
cloud data fusion instance citer and the
dataproc citer
thanks for watching and look out for
another video on the concepts of
networking for google cloud's managed
services
[Music]
you